♪ ♪ ♪
- Une cérémonie minutieusement
sanitaire étanche et une ville
placée sous haute surveillance.
Le président chinois participe
aux 25 ans de la rétrocession.ss
maîtres chez eux, déclare-t-il,é
avec la rétrocession."
Persécuté par le régimeKee a fi
Hong Kong. Il a construit
son refuge, sa librairie dédiée
à la liberté à Taipei.
Il affirme qu'il n'aurait
jamais pensé, il y a 25 ans,
que Hong Kong puisse être
le régime communiste chinois.L'e
devait jouir d'une certaine
autonomie, selon le principe
d'"un pays, deux systèmes",
mais la nationale imposée il y a
trois ans a anéanti
les libertés promises.
La Chine réécrit même
l'histoire, rappelle
cet activiste hongkongais exilé
manuels scolaires, Hong Kong
n'a jamais été une
britannique.
Il croit que Taïwan, mais
aussi le reste du monde,
dont le Canada, devrait retenir
les leçons de Hong Kong.
Taïwan est l'endroit-clé
à protéger pour sger pour sger r
la démocratie, croit-il.
Lam Wing Kee, lui, sent
que c'est sa respo
de défendre Taïwan.
Il organise des séminaires
jeunes dans sa librairie.
"Pas besoin de prendre
les armes pour se défendre,
dit-il, on peut lire pour
mieux comprendre."dente de Tdeï,
elle, soutient
que l'anniversaire
de la rétrocession de
Hong Kong ne fait
à défendre la souveraineté
et les libertés de
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Tai